drug overdoses skyrocketing states and
the federal government are looking for
new ways to tackle the crisis overdose
deaths surpassed 100 000 during the
12-month period ending april of 201
2021. that is up 28 percent from the
year prior the cause synthetic opioids
primarily fentanyl customs and border
protection says that most fentanyl
arrives in the u.s through ports of
entry along the southwest border in cars
and commercial trucks lilia luciano got
an exclusive look at new federal
government technology and spoke to a
parent who's trying to make a difference
right in here is where his ashes reside
i come here every morning and i kiss
this box and i kiss it at night before i
go to bed jaime puerta's son daniel was
16 when he died in 2020. when i opened
the door to his room on april the 1st
i saw my son lying with his arms across
his chest
his eyes were slit he was ashen gray and
he had a blue tint on top of his lip and
i just started screaming from the top of
my lungs daniel daniel daniel
near his son was half of what looked
like a blue oxycodone pill which puerta
says daniel bought from a dealer on
social media he was told his son had
overdosed i said an overdose i go what
did he overdose on the pill that he had
ingested was pure fentanyl this is not
an overdose this is a poisoning this is
an entirely different drug this is an
entirely different drug that my son
had absolutely no idea what he was
taking daniel had struggled with
substance use and mental health in the
past
but his dad says he wasn't addicted to
pain pills puerta says the way fentanyl
has transformed the drug landscape urges
a new conversation around drugs in which
there's little to no space for curiosity
or experimentation
the consumption of any kind
of illicit narcotic is like playing
russian relay with a loaded gun because
you don't know if it's going to take
your life 2021 was the deadliest year
for overdoses in the u.s since 2018 the
dea has seen more than a 50-fold
increase in the number of counterfeit
fentanyl pills seized and those
containing a lethal dose increased
dramatically
when teenagers attempt to purchase the
prescription drugs on the black market
more often than not they are sold
fentanyl colored sized and stamped to
look identical to the prescription drug
from 2014 to 2019 china was the leading
source of illegal fentanyl since then
mexico tops the list and while seizures
of cocaine meth and heroin by customs
and border protection have decreased in
recent months fentanyl continues to go
up it's more addicting and powerful than
other drugs and that makes it better
business in the black market
at the brownsville texas port of entry
stopping the rising flow of it is a
constantly evolving task how bad is it
right now
it was just very challenging at times
can be very challenging so here we see
the driver cbp director tater ortiz gave
us an inside look into the agency's
high-tech efforts
this is the latest and most powerful
technology that customs and border
protection is using at ports of entry to
take photos x-rays and detect any kind
of smuggled goods or people across the
border they believe it will help curb
the national fentanyl crisis
how many are going through the x-ray
we're doing approximately 70 80 percent
is being scanned and adjudicated right
now what was that number in the past we
were in the low 20s oh wow brownsville
is one of at least two ports of entry
using this new technology so far two out
of 328 nationwide but the federal
government hopes to expand it further
this equipment we call pre-primary
before the trailer actually meets the
officer so we have time to adjudicate it
before it arrives to us which allows us
times to adjudicate the image
and speed the process up it's more
efficient because you know before you
have that interaction with the officer
the officer can better target who needs
to have that yes we now know what's in
that trailer already not just based on
the manifest but now we have an actual
image to marry it up with jaime puerta
can't fight the supply of drugs but he
started a foundation to educate teens
and parents hoping awareness in the
classroom and at home can help save
lives we're not going to arrest our way
out of this education is key we have to
get the education into our high schools
even if it scares them and where do you
find solace
i find solace
knowing that my son is in a much better
place than i am
and that he will be waiting for me when
it's my time to go
and that he could say dad
you did good in my name
you did your best
i saw you trying to save lives i'm proud
of you dad
part of puerta's advocacy is now
awakening people to the ways that
fentanyl has transformed the entire drug
landscape and how it's now not just
impacting addicts but experienced
recreational drug users curious teens
anyone taking a drug from the black
market i asked them well there's decades
of data that shows that just say no
campaigns the ones from the past have
not worked so what's your message he
said look the way things are now
especially for young people who don't
have access to drug testing strips or
safe injection sites or things like that
don't do drugs is all he can really
you said it was going to be a very
powerful ending but that was that was a
whole different level and let's not miss
the point that he's making i love when
he said we cannot arrest her way out of
this situation these kids don't know
what they're doing no they don't know he
says my son was not overdosed my son was
poisoned
it's a big difference it's so strong one
one experimentation one effort
can be the last one yeah and it's on
everything it's on cocaine it's on
heroin it's on pills and the pills are
counterintuitive it makes a great point
that education needs to go into the
schools exactly because that's where
these drugs are finding their way into
yeah it's good to see you and great to
see you
good to be with you all and finally meet
you in first please come back more often
oh i will and bring your name lilia
luciano i say you have the best name on
television because who goes to your mind
rolls right off the tongue it's the same
as my mom so she loves her
shout out to your mom